That was kind of a quack.
Yeah.
And I was like,
all right,
he did.
Once they start talking about toxins,
you know,
we're cleansing you toxins.
Like,
oh,
that's a narrative.
Yeah,
it's possible.
Let's not prove it.
Right.
It's just a possible story you tell yourself.
Yeah.
But that term toxins is,
so that is like,
there's certain things that people say,
well,
you know,
you're dealing with a woo woo woo bullshit here.
And toxins is one of them.
Cleansing and toxins.
I'm going on a class and I'm,
I'm,
I'm getting the toxins out of my system.
The scientists are just as guilty as ou is.
Every other guy you think so big time.
In what way?
Oh my God,
man.
Like there's,
there's scientists then there's philosophers of science.
There's so much Wu in science,
even the most popular guys have woo.
They just never studied the philosophy of science.
So they don't really understand what they're saying per say.
Like,
give me an example of we wound,
so I'll give you,
I'll give you a great result.
Okay.
Um,
does this guy named Isaac Newton?
Okay.
All heard of that dude?
Yeah.
And you're asking him,
Hey Isaac,
why don't I fall off the face of the earth?
And he's going to be like,
well,
Joe,
there's this gravity.
This is the force of gravity pulling you down to the earth.
The earth has a greater mass than you.
Therefore it's,
there's this force pulling you down.
We call it gravity and then some guy comes around,
his name is,
is a hobby and he tells,
you know,
Joel,
don't listen to that guy.
I have another theory way more.
It's truer than his.
I believe there are gremlins pulling it down to the earth.
They have last souls.
He's infinite long last was,
and every time you're falling off the earth,
they pull you.
Every time you jump up and down on the earth,
they pull you back down to the earth.
You don't see these gremlins.
They're invisible.
But that's what's pulling you down to the earth.
Now,
how do you know who's right and who's wrong?
Who's telling you the truth?
Me Or Isaac.
Isaac lived a long time ago before they actually had provable studies that could
show you why gravity works.
Navy,
one of those studies.
Well,
I'm not a scientist.
Well No,
let me,
let me break it to you this way.
No scientist has a study to prove us that gravity works.
That's the whole thing.
That's,
that's what's scary about.
But he would talk about the university and understand that gravity is in
relation to the size and massive objects.
So the moon is smaller,
therefore it has one six earth's gravity cause it's one quarter the size of the
earth.
There's a standard formula to follow.
There's a correlation.
Now My,
my theory of Gremlins,
which obviously I don't believe it,
right?
I'm using the theological language to make it really sip.
Don't somebody misquote me that I've,
you know,
he doesn't believe in gravity is gravity denier.
Exactly.
Well,
I have,
there's less.
There's less mass on.
There's less items that the moon has less Adams.
Therefore less gremlins lesser than pulling you might might.
Gremlin theory correlates with the gravity theory.
Exactly.
But I'm using a myth,
mythical language just to point out that every type of force we're talking about
is an inference.
It's something we project out there.
We don't actually see gravity.
And you know,
later on,
Einstein debunked gravity,
right?
What do you mean by he [inaudible] Isaac was wrong.
Isaac,
Isaac's explanation of why you don't fall off the earth was totally wrong.
Well,
what did Einstein due to debunk it?
Einstein taught us that and new theory and new hypothesis that gravity is a
pushing force,
not a pulling force.
See Isaac Newton,
he debunked Aristotle
first.
We still believe that Aristotle used to say our studies to say,
look,
this thing has a a natural place.
It has to be stuck to the earth.
That's his natural place.
It the forces within that one thing.
That's why it doesn't fall off the earth.
So when Aristotle saw bird fly,
he said it,
look,
it has levity,
it's natural status to be in the air.
The force that it carries it up in the air.
It's within it to within the bird itself.
Isaac Newton came around and said,
no,
that's totally wrong.
Nobody,
no,
no entity can move itself.
It's only a force that's applied.
So let's say you're walking Isaac Newton would say,
you're not pushing yourself forward.
You're pushing the ground beneath you backwards
and that the ground is pushing you forwards so that every action has an opposite
equal reaction.
So when I run,
I'm really pushing the ground behind me.
It sounds like,
like he's splitting hairs,
but he's saying something actually very profound.
He's saying,
you're pushing the earth behind you and the earth is pushing you forward.
There's a reaction there.
So what they do to,
to illustrate that to kids is they take like a train track,
the elevated,
and they turn on the train and then you see the train track starting to spin
underneath the train and it's showing you look,
the train is pushing the train tracks back and the train tracks are pushing the
train forward when they're,
when they're connected to the ground.
So when I put you on a treadmill,
you're pushing the treadmill behind you,
the treadmill's not pushing you forward because it's,
it's spinning along with you.
And if I put you on the ground,
the ground is pushing you forward now.
So for every action is opposite equal reaction.
I'm sure you heard this.
Then Einstein comes along and says,
no,
that's totally wrong.
Well,
when it comes to gravity,
okay,
when subject to gravity says,
because Isaac Newton says this,
look,
he says,
the force of gravity is in the earth.
The earth has this invisible force,
this magical wool thing.
And that's what,
that's what is contemporary set about him.
That's what is pure said.
He said,
you're appealing to magic.
What does gravity thing where it's not,
it's not [inaudible],
it's not material.
It's not made of a substance is this magic?
And he was like,
yeah,
it's this forced.
You can't feel it.
You can't detect it.
It's just observable in nature.
And for 300 years,
everybody believed that.
And then I think as long says,
no,
you guys are totally wrong.
There is no mythical force called gravity.
It's a pushing force.
So really what he says is,
Oh sorry,
let me,
let me get a sheet of paper here.
Make it really,
really simple.
And I'm going to put it in a nutshell here.
Okay?
But,
okay,
this is,
he says,
look,
Einstein says,
space and time are one space is actually a thing out there.
It's actually a fee.
The space between me and you is actual physical thing.
He says,
the sun is so heavy that it dents it,
it makes it,
it makes like a totally the ball and the earth is bumping around in that toilet
bowl because space is actually curved.
It's curved like this
spaces curve because the sun,
imagine that.
Put something,
a bowling ball on your bed.
You,
your,
your bed's going to indent right?
That bolt,
that toilet bowl shape the world.
The earth is flowing around the toilet bowl shapes.
It's a pushing force.
No longer a pulling force.
So the weight of the earth is pushing down on space.
Exactly.
It's bending space.
Literally it's masses bending space.
Now,
Isaac Newton thought lights travels in a straight line only.
And to prove this,
Einstein said,
look,
light will bend.
If I'm right,
So they observe the sun during an eclipse and they saw that the light bends
light does not travel in a straight line.
And this was another,
um,
uh,
belief there was debug.
I mean,
how many scientific beliefs are debunked countless or overturned because a
scientific fact is not a mathematical fact are two different things as
scientific fact and never go higher than hypothesis.
If somebody understands the philosophy of science,
he understands that every single scientific fact is not equivalent to a
mathematical fact.
One plus one equals to a scientific fact is always subject to cross examination
and new evidence.
Oh,
you've ever heard of Thomas Kuhn?
He's very famous for that,
right?
We have a paradigm.
So during Aristotle's time he had a paradigm.
You thought the sun goes around the earth.
It was an observational,
scientific fact.
Every day he saw the sun go around the earth.
Literally he said,
look guys,
I'm using my senses to observe the sun go around the earth.
And then one day we find that no,
that's an optical illusion.
It's not true that the sun goes around.
The earth is the earth,
goes around the sun side,
the scientific revolution,
every scientific fact we have,
or theory,
including gravity,
because gravity became the law of gravity.
It wasn't the longer the theory of gravity,
it was so accepted,
it became the law of gravity.
Today we don't,
we don't understand gravity as Einstein understood it.
Excuse me,
as Isaac Newton understood.
We understand it completely backwards,
literally backwards now.
And that's true with every scientific theory because science is always subject
to new evidence coming to light where,
but the difference between Isaac Newton living like when,
whenever the fuck he lived so long ass time ago,
CNG years ago versus the science that we're dealing with today.
Like it's a science today.
But what we'll,
we'll do you see in the science of today?
Um Oh,
the biggest culprit.
Yes.
A randomness.
See,
it's funny because I heard you this conversation with the Sam Harris on
randomness,
which I love by the way.
You did a great job.
I thought it was a great conversation.
However,
he was giving you my opinion,
two contradictory ideas.
Who's tell you,
look,
the world is determined,
but also there'll be random events.
And I found that all he was actually talking about determinism versus free will,
right?
Yeah.
So the idea of being that you don't necessarily have free will,
that everything about your decisions and what you're going to do is based on
your life experiences,
your genetics,
all these variables that are essentially out of your control.
So this idea of free will is an illusion,
which is a really complex conversation and I think you could see it in both
ways.
I think you do have a certain amount of control of your decisions and I think
you were shaped very much so by your past and your genetics and your
interpretation of those events.
What are those interpretations of those events though?
And why do you make those determinations?
W who,
who's,
who's in your head pulling the gears?
Like what,
what are you,
I'm a hard determinist.
Like I'm a very hard determinist determinist extremist.
So,
but do you believe in free will?
I also believe in free will,
which is,
which is tricky.
It's just tricky.
But I think that's,
it's true.
A potting the both further examination.
I think that's there's,
there is something that allows people to,
I mean,
what,
what takes the guy was 500 pounds and all of sudden he goes on a Keto diet and
starts running and w who starts walking in the knee,
he sends you a picture on Twitter.
I lost 179 pounds in six months.
You're like,
Holy Shit,
how the fuck did you do?
Like that guy has a fucking wheel man to say that.
That's his whole life and his life experiences and as genetics it's like,
yes,
I could see what you're saying.
I could see that he,
he had enough because of his life experiences and that led to him making this
change.
But this is a tremendous amount of will involved in that.
And to deny that seems like you're denying the spirit of human beings.
Well,
let's look at it this way.
Okay,
real quick,
let's look at it like,
okay,
let's say a couple of this piece of paper
and I'm going to catapult it,
okay?
And it landed there,
right?
And I'm going to reset the entire universe.
I'm going to reset every molecule of air,
every fiber in this paper,
you're going to be in the exact same spot.
The whole universe has been reset and a fire.
It again isn't going to land exactly where it landed the first time,
or is it going to land somewhere else?
I've reset the universe.
The earth was the earth.
Every molecule of matter in the,
every,
every particle of matter in the universe has been reset with the same amount of
force.
Everything is identical.
I would assume if the same amount of space and the same amount of air,
you would land the same spot infinitely.
Precisely.
I don't know what every set everything perfectly.
If,
if infinitely precisely.
You throw it exact,
exact same way and it lands in the exact same dirt with the exact same
resistance.
It's the same thing.
I would assume it's infinitely precisely gonna land the same spot if random,
this is a force at work in nature.
Why didn't it factor itself into our little experiment here?
Cause you little experiments,
impossible.
But that's irrelevant.
It's a thought experiment,
but it's not a fun creating logical universe.
Right?
But it's not logically impossible.
Well,
in that case though,
with the variables that you presented,
yes.
Okay,
well,
where's randomness?
Where's this?
Four is no randomness.
If you're recreating the entire earth in a,
in a very duplicatable way,
that's not randomness at all.
It is random.
There is no randomness,
right?
Random.
This is when a human being can no longer compute all the factors.
And he,
we use an expression called randomness,
meaning,
okay,
I rolled the dice had landed on on seven randomly.
Why?
Because
I couldn't compute all the variables.
So the random,
this is kind of a,
it's a,
it's an illusion that we project onto the world.
So the plus one of the greatest physicists and history,
okay,
a similar place.
He says,
look,
look at a billiard ball table.
Okay?
If you tell me which way you're going to break the billiard balls,
if you tell me what philocity and what angle you're gonna hit that,
that,
that Cuba,
I could tell you where every single ball is going to be on the pool table.
That's what laplace says.
Okay?
He's a phenomenal thinker.
And he says,
why?
Because I'm going to take that table.
I'm going to turn it to a math.
I'm going to take the weight of the ball,
the friction of the table,
the density of the bands,
the the,
the,
the gravity of the earth.
Excuse me.
I'm going to take all those variables.
I'm going to put them up on this board here.
All I need to know is how hard you can hit the ball.
And I'll tell you precisely where every ball is going to land.
Now,
somebody who doesn't know mathematics or geometry is going to look at that
table.
When he sees the brake to him.
It's going to seem random but random.
This is really a reflection of his ignorance.
He's not able to compute all this information.
That's why the plas says to God the world is not random to somebody who has
information.
The world is not random.
That's why he says it's very important to sweat.
That's where we're sold.
Determinist cause we believe that what's happening right now is a byproduct of
the past,
the past cause this happening right now.
The past was out of your control.
If I reset the universe and let it play all over again,
I identical circumstance,
you would drink that exact same amount of coffee you had today.
You would've made the same.
You would just married the same woman,
you would have had the same kids,
you would have had the same t shirt on.
Right now,
you'd have the Mike at the same.
This everything would be reset.
So when we look at the world through the eyes of physics,
they say the cause of Linus completes the cause of line is complete.
Meaning where is this space for randomness or freewill?
It.
We don't factor it in.
The only time we do factor it in is when we look at ourselves inwardly.
But when we look at the world objectively as a third person,
so there's two views.
There's the internal view.
First person experience.
We don't believe,
we don't believe in determinism where we have free will.
That's the first person experience.
Third Person Experience.
I'm studying Joe.
All I see in Joe is billiard balls.
So when you have a thought,
it's all billiard balls hitting one another.
And if I had an infinitely precise calculator according to the plus,
I could tell you where you're going to be five years from now,
what you're going to be doing.
Why?
Because I'm seeing one billiard ball hit another.
It's just take that pool table,
experiment and make it the greatest pool game in history,
there are countless atoms.
There are countless billiard balls striking into one another.
Somebody can calculate the world of physics and tell you where your hands going
to be.
Laplace says,
I'm going to tell you where your hand's going to be in five years from now,
but you don't know my personal choices.
I'm going to make it.
That's irrelevant.
That's a way he'll tell you.
Why?
Cause he sees the billiard balls moving inside your mind,
so to speak.
Now Leipnetz reconcile the two because see,
for instance,
when I,
when I living in the first person,
this is my intuition.
I'm like,
Hey,
I grabbed that Coffee Cup of coffee.
I had this internal experience.
It's outside of physics.
So lemon is gives a great example.
He says,
look,
if I was really,
really tiny and I'd walk around in your mind,
I would see blood flow.
I would see neurons firing.
I would see all sorts of biological,
uh,
interactions,
but I wouldn't see anything of consciousness.
I wouldn't see your thoughts.
I wouldn't see you thinking about your wife,
a hearing your child's voice,
thinking about what you want to have for dinner.
I wouldn't see any of that.
I would just see billiard balls hitting one another.
However,
now that I'm having this first person experience,
there's something we call intuition.
This first person experience itself,
you're having this spiritual type of transcendent experience.
What it's like to have a thought,
what it's like to be me.
So for instance,
I see the cup of coffee,
I desire the cup of coffee and I drink it.
Science says nothing has no information about my conscious experience.
My intuitive experience.
Science is not absolute.
They cannot tell me everything about the universe.
It could only tell me about the billiard balls.
It can only go so far.
At that point it has to stop because it doesn't have,
we don't,
our census cannot sense the conscious experience that we're having.
The conscious experience has only known intuitively.
So first person experience,
so 11 it says this.
It says,
look,
you look at the world when you study the world,
we're all seeing billiard balls hitting one another.
Nobody argues about that.
However,
our intuition is telling us that's all untrue.
We have the chat,
we have the ability to move our own hand,
desire something,
grab something,
eat something,
consumed something,
make a choice.
And he says,
how are the two,
how could they coexist?
Because remember in reason for me to accept something as logically true,
after eliminate every other possibility.
So he found the one possibility,
one possibility that till today it's never been refuted.
He says,
he calls it the twin trains.
So picture two trains.
Okay?
They're going up and down,
side by side,
traveling at the same speed.
They look like they're connected to one another,
but they're not.
They're just synchronized.
Every time one goes left,
the other one goes left,
one goes up,
one goes down.
And so when I lighten this tells you this,
says,
look,
when you reach for that cup of coffee,
the universe had already decided millions of billions of years ago that that was
going to happen.
Your intuitive sense just coincides with it perfectly.
And he said,
that's what he calls the twin trains theory.
That the correlation theory that your desire to grab that cup of coffee doesn't
affect your hand,
does not move your hand.
That'll be impossible.
There'll be something nonphysical moving,
something physical.
So he says that they're just correlated perfectly.
When you ask them how do they correlate so perfectly,
he says,
well,
God,
it's like God took the girls the greatest pool shot in history.
This is [inaudible].
This is a,
he's a,
he's the guy who invented the calculus,
the binary code,
you know,
like w all our computers.
So work cause of the cause
of Lebanon's.
That to me is a hard sell.
Yeah.
So most people can't wrap their mind around it.
It's a hard sell.
First of all,
he can put a woman can created the first computer code.
Uh,
he,
he invented that binary code,
binary Kaline,
Enrico.
Not Computer Call,
but the base on binary.
Now when he's saying he's saying this,
that your desire coincides with the universe having this,
that seems like a lot of woo.
That seems like a bit of a stretch.
That's an interesting point.
Tell me why.
Well,
why would the universe have a plan for you and your mother?
He's saying,
God,
he's saying God directly.
Well,
prove that.
Okay.
That's a great,
that's a great,
that's a great objection.
Why would you say that it would be gone?
It's argument.
It wasn't to proof God.
This argument was to tell you that this is a possibility.
Why you freewill is true and so as determinism.
Yes,
because can you deny freewill aren't you're having a direct experience of free
will?
Well,
the only denial of freewill would be determinism.
The only denial would be that your idea of free will is an illusion is you are
really shaped by the momentum of your past,
your genetics,
live experiences,
all the variables and the way you've absorbed emotions and interactions with
people and that these are flavored.
Your very being to the point when when presented with an obstacle or an
opportunity or a thing,
there is a predetermined solution in your mind for whatever the situation is.
That's determinism.
Okay?
So let,
let's,
uh,
let's say action rather than solution.
Let's take a step back and look at what live minutes is trying to say.
Okay?
He's trying to say,
look,
there's three ways of knowing something and yeah,
you have to decide this is a brilliant human being.
Okay.
And not many,
many,
many men have have said the same thing throughout history.
Let's,
let's just at least entertain it.
He says,
look,
you know something empirically through your senses,
okay,
you touch fire,
it's hot.
Then you can know something.
Deductively one plus one equals two via logic.
Then you could know something intuitively meaning direct first experience.
Okay,
so let's that.
So let's say,
um,
let's say you tell me,
I dunno.
Um,
I've had the coffee tastes great.
You don't know that deductively or empirically the sensation of coffee tasting
great is known intuitively direct meaning there is no,
um,
there is no interpreter and philosophy of something called the egocentric
predicament.
So right now you're experiencing this entire room within your consciousness,
right?
[inaudible] I might be outside of Your Eagle,
but I'm,
I'm occurring right now in your consciousness.
You see the different perceiving you.
So yeah,
in my consciousness,
yes.
Or with my consciousness,
which is connected to my senses.
Is there anything you can perceive outside of your consciousness?
Well,
that's a weird say way of saying something that's imposed anything but
perceiving outside of my consciousness.
Meaning not being,
not conscious,
but yet still perceiving.
No.
When you perceive something,
it has to be within your consciousness,
right?
You have to or with your consciousness,
It cannot be outside of your branch.
So even if something touches your skin,
you're consciously recognizing that it touches your skin.
Um,
the egocentric predicament is more about your whole universe is made up of your
consciousness.
You cannot sense anything or experience anything or get any information outside
of your conscious.
Like camp was very big on this.
He's like,
look this,
this is called idealism and the whole world is happening on inside your head,
right?
Supposedly likes,
for instance,
you see this cup of coffee,
they're gonna say like clusters hit the cup of coffee.
It goes in your eye,
your eye,
your eye.
It gives your brain a signal.
You're sick.
Your brain interprets the signal and creates this universe around you.
Creates this image.
The theater of your mind.
Yeah.
Can you experience anything outside of the theater of your mind?
Very difficult to argue that you could.
It's impossible.
Yeah.
According to all the philosophers in history,
we,
we can't,
we cannot.
This is called the egocentric particular.
What about subconscious that will be still happening inside your conscious mind?
So subconscious is still some what?
Conscious in some way?
Yes.
It will be whatever.
Whatever you would perceive would be happening in your conscious mind would just
be outside of your standard awareness.
Now the scary thing is is that we have,
we make a lot of inferences and that's where the wool wool comes in.
Everything is will,
will you think just he think just everything outside of sides is what woo
sciences just as Wu was everyone else's.
You keep saying that,
but I don't understand why you're saying it because you haven't made a good
example.
Okay.
We'll only example that you said was that they changed the way they look at
gravity when new information was presented,
right.
That doesn't equal.
We'll,
we'll gravity was Wu will.
It was a magical force.
My grandma,
my grandma,
think about gravity in terms of people that didn't even,
didn't have phones,
they didn't have cars,
they didn't have paved roads.
I mean,
you're dealing with a very primitive notion of what gravity was.
It was a very interesting idea that has since been proven to be true.
False gravity,
Newtonian gravity.
Okay.
Has been proven to be false,
but gravity is still real,
right?
Not we're using the same word for a completely different idea,
okay,
so Newton's gravity was magical.
It was an appeal to magic.
Okay,
here it is.
Here is gravity is different than Einstein's gravity and that Einstein's gravity
is what's been proven,
right?
We know now that light does bend around the mass of the sun,
which is one of the reasons why we have a hard time seeing asteroids that are
coming from behind the sun because the mass of the sun actually Ben Space Time
around it to the point where it distorts our view.
It's our new narrative.
It's not proven.
You can never prove a scientific fact past the level of hypothesis.
It's weird.
I know it sounds strange,
but what do you mean pass the level of hypothesis?
If you can prove it in studies and tests and you still don't buy it,
you have not eliminated every other possibility.
Okay,
so it's not the same as a logical fi.
How is that?
Whoa,
this is,
this is understood in,
in,
in like in the philosophy of science.
It's quick.
It's comfortably accepted.
It's not anti science like I'm not trying to say anything.
I know.
I know you're not,
but you're going to love it.
You were saying that science has so much woo and I'm not seeing the woo.
Part of what I'm seeing is the necessary testing and the idea of incorporating
new data or changing beliefs and ideas.
This is quite a,
it's a bit of a difficult thing to wrap your mind off it in one day,
but you have to think about it and throughout time you [inaudible] it comes to
clearer and clearer.
When we observe the universe,
all we see is patterns and regularities found in nature.
That's it.
We don't see actual physical laws.
The physical laws are bookmarks inside our mind.
We see the same pattern over and over again,
and then we attribute a physical law,
but that physical art doesn't exist out there.
So here,
here's a great example.
Okay?
Okay.
Let me give you a great example.
Let's say I'm about to flip a coin.
Okay.
[inaudible] now you're going to tell me it's probably going to land on heads or
tails.
Yeah.
[inaudible] do you know that logically or is it based on your history with
coins?
I know it logically and based on my history of coins.
Perfect.
I'm arguing.
You don't know it logically.
You only know what on your past history.
Okay,
so pay attention to this.
This is,
this is a little bit weird.
This is what we got to.
We had to go slow.
It gets a very weird,
okay?
It's very,
uh,
it goes against our instincts.
Okay?
Erase all your history with coins.
You've never seen a coin before,
okay?
And I flip it right?
And now it turns into a butterfly.
You've never seen a coin before.
It doesn't surprise you.
You're like,
well,
turn into a butterfly.
And I flipped a coin a hundred times in front of you a hundred times.
It turns into a butterfly.
Now I'm going to flip the coin a hundred,
the hundred and one time.
You can be like,
I bet you it turns into a butterfly.
That's how we express science.
We see the patterns and regularities,
then we,
we predict them science.
This is good.
This is a little bit,
this is a good way to put it.
Science is the faith.
It's faith that the future will behave like the past.
Science is faith
that the future will behave like the past.
So now you've developed a faith that this coin will flip into a butterfly
and now you can predict it.
Wouldn't you say that science is the use of measurement to understand matter and
things around us?
I wouldn't say that it's using the past to predict a future.
I would say that if you know that fire melts led at a certain temperature and
this is provable,
and then you can show this over and over again.
Here's what we know about fire and reaches a certain temperature.
When led reaches a certain temperature,
it melts.
It changes its form.
Whereas if you want to do that same test to carbon based,
steal a requires far greater temperatures and then we know that there's
variables in matter.
This is,
this is not,
this is something that you can prove and show.
There's no woo to that.
Okay.
Water boils at how many degrees?
I think it's two 50 and in southeast,
a hundred degrees Celsius.
I Dunno what Fahrenheit.
Oh,
you Canadians with your wacky metric system.
Is that a side effect?
Is it a scientific fact that water boils at a certain temperature?
Yes.
Actually,
no.
It's not,
they can boil water now they can.
Water can resist boiling up to 200 degrees Celsius if you put it in a certain
atmospheric atmospheric pressure and then suspended in a certain liquid.
If you change the circumstance,
suspend water and liquids,
they suspended in a particular liquid that's,
that's not heated or cooled.
Alright?
It's not,
it's not supposed to.
It doesn't affect the temperature of the water itself.
And now water can boil at 200 degrees.
Okay,
so you're doing something different to water.
That's,
I think you're taking it outside of the normal earth environment.
So the variables also include Earth's environment.
Agreed.
But water doesn't inherently boil at a hundred degrees.
It's not a fact.
But we believe that to be a scientific,
we believe that water,
if it gets to a hundred degrees,
is boiling.
It's going to behave this way.
As a matter of fact,
no.
There are many other things that,
that that fact has been debunked and there's countless amount of facts.
Like wait a minute,
is that the facts have been debunked or is that when you add in sufficient
external variables,
then water takes longer to boil because of these variables playing into yes.
The,
the properties that we already observed with water.
That's why whenever we have a scientific factor,
might be new information coming to,
to change our view,
change our view of this fact.
This is not necessarily new information.
What this is,
is new,
additional,
precise,
more precise information.
But what you're talking about with water,
you're talking about additional variables.
Like that's just more science.
That's not woo.
Okay,
well here's some cool,
okay.
This is because we talk about gravity was woo.
Like hey random,
this was whew.
Okay.
Cause we,
we cannot find one instance of actual randomness.
The causal line is complete as Laplas would say.
There's no randomness in the world.
So the randomness ideas is just our inability to calculate exactly.
Believably difficult variables.
Exactly.
But the,
it's,
it's a projection of your increments.
If you knew you wouldn't be random.
So,
for instance,
um,
I can't remember who coined the term,
but they say,
the man who says the tallest mountain I've ever seen is the tallest mountain
he's making himself.
The measure of truth.
I measure truth.
If you take that perspective,
you're the center of truth.
I'm truth.
There's nothing outside of me that's true.
Then you see randomness everywhere.
However,
if you believe in correspondence theory,
that truth is independent of me and you,
which I think most of us will agree,
then random is,
doesn't exist in that context because
randomness,
it only depends on you and when things are true outside of your beliefs,
right?
Let's take another classic.
We'll,
we'll term,
I know this is a very advanced philosophy.
I know it sounds crazy,
okay?
But this is,
this is,
this is what the greatest thinkers in history,
in a report,
okay?
With what they've written down,
Okay.
See this,
uh,
you see a knife?
I,
let's look at Aristotle's theory of knives.
Okay?
Says,
look at,
look at this slide.
I show you a plastic knife.
I show you a wooden knife.
I show you a metal knife.
I show you five different knives and you're like,
they're all knives.
All of them are knives.
You pointed them and say their knives.
Aristotle says,
look,
they all share in one something.
Let's call it the essence that makes them all knives.
Would you agree?
The form they all share,
they fight,
draw knife on a paper and be like,
he just drew a knife.
That knife on the paper.
Share something with a knife made of steel.
The knife made of plastic.
Okay.
The knife made of wood.
The form.
There's something about it.
We call it the essence in philosophy.
Okay?
The form might be confused with what a Plato says.
Split on how the whole thing about forms,
but let's call it for now essence.
Okay?
If you change the essence,
you change the thing.
So if I take that piece of that,
if I take that plastic a knife and I melt it,
you realize it's not a knife anymore,
right?
Why?
What did I do?
You change that thing about it.
That essence right now,
that essence,
does it exist out there in the world or is it only in your head you made it up?
Okay.
Well,
by calling in essence,
you're confusing me,
so I would call it the form.
Okay.
The form of it,
it sort of exists in culture that exists in our understanding of these objects
and then useful shapes.
It's you,
it's your,
your idea of,
of knife conforms to that knife out there.
Where's that knife right here?
That's a great,
yeah.
Bring it out.
You can see it.
Great.
It's obviously a knife.
Yes.
Right.
You recognize it or recognize it.
That's a knife.
Yeah.
I totally agree.
Mike.
Model of Nice.
Yeah.
My motto of knife that fits my model.
Mine is beautiful,
but there's some weird looking knives out there too.
Sure.
And there might be a knife where we don't agree.
That's a night.
You think it's an f?
I don't agree.
That's,
I think that's a sword reached a level of sorts,
right?
Yeah.
We might have a different that.
That's great evidence.
That's something in our minds,
not actually objective.
Right,
right,
right.
They get to the certain length.
It's subjective.
It's subjective,
right?
Right.
Okay.
Let's look at matter now matter.
Okay?
It's an inference of the mind.
Just like the,
the knife is an inference of the mind
in terms of subatomic particles and atoms.
And you see this cup,
you see this bottle?
Yes.
You see this clock?
You made an inference.
They all share one thing.
What did they share?
All of them share one thing.
What does that thing they share?
They share this thing called matter.
Okay.
But that's,
that was an inference.
Just like we inferred the essence of a knife matter has never been observed in
nature.
Matter is a byproduct of our mind.
Okay,
so when you see a tree,
hmm,
you're not seeing matter.
There's no matter is only,
not that I'm inferring matter,
I'm observing an image.
Right?
But I'm inferring
the matter.
The matter is,
it is a mental construct.
Is it a mental construct or is it our inability to see things smaller than what
is necessary for our survival?
Like we can't see Adam's,
we can't see subatomic particles.
We can't see them with the naked eye.
But we understand through science that they exist.
How do you understand that they exist?
Are you seeing that matter exists out there independently of your mind?
Is matter objective or is it dependent on your mind to exist?
It's not dependent on your mind to exist.
It's too dependent upon your mind to observe your,
you need your mind to be able to observe matter.
Okay.
So matter,
if you didn't exist,
do you think this table would exist?
That,
I dunno.
Right?
But what would you guess?
I would guess that all I know if I'm going to use Ockham's razor,
you know,
if you've heard of aqua,
if I'm going to go to the extreme with Ockham's razor,
I'm just going to believe what I observe.
Okay.
Kill all the wool.
Kill it all.
You have had loved one die,
right?
Yeah.
Everyone has.
Right?
Um,
do you assume that when they die,
the universe is still the universe?
What do you mean still the university?
It's like the world is the way they are.
I mean the,
the way it is,
there's trees and grass and dirt and this person dies.
The trees and grass and dirt.
They don't change.
They're still the same thing.
What do you mean that the nature of the tree would change it?
No,
I'm saying if you love someone and you know this person and they are no longer
with us,
all the things around you like this coffee cup and this knife,
they stayed,
remained the same.
They don't change.
No,
they don't change.
Why would you assume that it would be any different for yourself if you weren't
here?
Why would you think that this table would not exist for the microphone?
Would not say that's a great argument.
I'm not thinking it wouldn't.
That's this is what we call hard objectivity.
Something that's hard.
Objectivity exist without any human mind in exist.
If all human minds were dead,
whatever exists still is what we would call philosophers called hard
objectivity.
Now we have objectivity,
so for instance,
let's look at the George Berkeley's example is,
that's such a great question.
Look at a triangle.
Okay.
Picture a blue triangle.
Picture a green.
One picture of black,
one picture or white one.
Can you picture one with no subjective elements?
Meaning.
Because color is subjective,
right?
Color is a construct of the mind.
So if I was colorblind,
this shirt would be a different color to me than it is to you,
right?
However,
they would still be one shirt.
It would be objective to a certain degree.
Okay,
so triangle has three,
three sides,
three corners.
It adds up to 180 degrees.
We all agree it.
Whether you're colorblind,
it doesn't matter,
right?
There's no subjective element to how many points does it have?
Nobody's going to come in and say to me,
triangles have three,
four sites.
Right?
You'd be like,
that's not a triangle.
There's not three angles to that,
right?
You've,
you've gone past it a little cool understanding.
Okay,
so can you,
George Berkeley says,
can you a triangle without any subjective elements,
without any color?
Let's call it color.
To make it really simple,
really,
really obvious.
Can you picture a triangle without any color?
You would have to have it in contrast to something so that you could see it.
Like if you had a say,
if you had a purple curtain,
like what we have behind us and out of that Purple Carton we cut a triangle.
Even if there was no color,
if it was just clear,
you would be able to see.
You'd be able to differentiate between that shape,
but she needed that purple curtain to differentiate so we cannot have it without
subjective element.
This was Berkeley's point.
Exactly what you said.
I see what you're saying.
Beautiful.
Every objective thing we've observed in the universe has,
this is made up of subjective elements.
Even when you draw the number one on a blackboard,
it has to be a color asked to be something and it has to be a contrast.
Like you said,
it's beautiful.
He said it beautifully.
All our objective elements or mental constructs,
three sides.
The idea of side is a mental construct.
The idea of a point is a mental construct idea of 180 degrees is mathematical.
It's happening in your mind somewhere,
right?
It's not out.
They're being observed.
You can draw it and I can see it and I can repeat it and you can teach it to me
and I can teach it to someone else.
Like these are,
they may be mental constructs,
provable mental constructs that are repeatable.
So there we threw an agreement is a real thing.
We're in agreement that mathematics is a mental construct and it's true.
It's definitely by the finish and true.
So both a mental construct and trust,
but it's not outside out there in the world within.
But if you make a triangle on the ground,
it's in the world.
The numbers are in your head and the subjective element is in the world.
There's a two way street.
The subjective element is in the world,
but it's a triangle.
So,
so how's it in your head?
Because you,
when you look at a triangle,
the subjective elements,
when you observe them in your mind,
your mind points out different objective elements of that triangle.
But it's dependent on your mind.
By that argument,
the entire universe is dependent on your mind.
Absolutely.
No doubt about it.
If we're going to use OCKHAM's razor,
yes,
but not everyday language.
We use an outcomes.
Let's take away everything.
We're not sure of everything that has a doubt.
Get rid of it.
Okay.
Get rid of everything with a sliver of the league.
Ever heard or the problem that they can't matter itself as a sliver of doubt?
Absolutely.
Well,
when you have subatomic particles that you know they exist in two different
states simultaneously.
They're both spinning and still there in superstates,
Berkeley would tell you those are images of subatomic particles.
They're not lump sum up t sub atomic particles independent of your mind.
Well,
I had a conversation with Sean Carroll about it.
It was a physicist and he made it familiar,
even more muddy to me.
I thought,
I thought it was crazy before I talked him and then when I talked to him,
he's brilliant,
he's brilliant.
He's essentially saying that subatomic particles don't blink in and out of
existence.
It's just we,
it's the way we're looking at them and that they exist in this just bizarre
state,
but they exist in this state in a way that it's very difficult for us to use
normal language to sort of explain.
Exactly.
That's,
that's the issue.
But you know what?
I might have fucked.
He's probably listening to them.
It's like you fucking dummy.
You know,
and what I said again,
you know what?
What a great one.
Great conversation.
I heard a conversation between Jordan Peterson and Sam Harris.
Oh,
that the conversation about truth.
I loved it.
Although it drove me crazy.
I think we could do better though.
Yes.
I think they could have done better to moderator.
Yes,
exactly.
Exactly.
Do you need to get to know each other personally first?
They never met by the way.
That's it's,
that's fireworks,
right?
That was such a great conversation.
But here's my question.
What's the difference between knowledge and belief?
Because a lot of what we said,
it's kind of muddy.
Okay,
let's make it suit.
Let's make,
let's make the water's crystal clear as much as possible.
Okay.
What is the difference between knowledge and belief?
Well,
the belief that the gremlins are pulling down on people,
which is why we have gravity.
That would be a belief.
No,
they're both beliefs.
Well,
Dad,
gravity's not knowledge.
It's a belief.
Okay,
but we're talking about Graham ones where I was going to say that's knowledge or
that's,
that's a belief.
Belief,
knowledges.
If I throw water on your,
you get wet.
Hmm.
I would say that's a belief to believe.
Yes.
So maybe one day I throw water on you and Youtube,
show me that you're cheeses and the water just goes right through you.
And it does.
The reason why you believe water will make me wet is because it happened in the
past.
Now you think that the future is going to behave like the past.
Just like Aristotle saw the sun go around the earth and he thought that this is
going to happen every day.
He didn't understand.
I understand.
It's optical illusion.
Let me get,
let me want to understand better is though.
It's each to,
okay,
throw it out.
She get wet.
All flamingos are pink.
They're not.
We didn't know that all the time.
Did we?
Then we went to Australia.
They don't have the same food source.
They don't have the same food sorts of their black here.
They're white here.
They have a different food source.
Flamingos are not inherently pink as a scientific fact that can always be
overturned.
This is,
he threw water and didn't get wet.
Yeah,
but this is not just because it's a,
it's a certain coding.
Right.
I got you.
But if he's got that over,
his body's not going to be able to breathe.
Okay.
How about this?
You've never seen fire before.
You've never seen five K and you've been being,
you've been being warmed by electric blanket your entire life.
Okay.
Then you see a flame and you don't know.
Can you know that that flame is going to burn you if you touch it logically or
is it only via experience?
Through history,
developing a history,
a relationship with fire.
A bird you once it burns you twice,
you're like,
hey,
but I think the future is going to behave like the past.
Who Know that fire burns you and they've never been burned by fire because they
went to school and they learn from people who explained the properties of fire,
what it is,
how it works,
what temperature it operates on,
how it's different depending upon the color of it or what's burning.
Borrowed history,
borrowed history.
It's still history,
How so?
You learn from my mistakes of touching fire.
Okay,
but it's still known VR experience for your history.
Well,
it's known via science.
If you explain exactly what the elements of the fire are and how it works and
what it burns at and what temperature specific things need to burn out,
you don't have to get burned to know that it will burn you.
No,
no,
but that's how we discovered fire burns by testing it.
Not via logical deduction.
Okay,
I see what you're saying.
It's only history.
Science is pattern is irregularities found in nature.
We observe nature.
We see these patterns and regularities.
Right?
We have no idea what's causing them.
Well wasn't that day cards original idea about science in the first place was
using measurement to sort of understand nature well was then one of his original
concepts of establishing science in the first place?
No,
his original concept was they look,
science is doubtable.
He said that science is doubtable L.
Dot.
It's called Cartesian dealt extreme level of doubt.
He says,
those are all beliefs.
I don't have any knowledge.
What do,
what do I know?
Because knowledge means zero chance of being wrong.
Okay,
zero chance of being wrong.
Give me one scientific fact.
You truly trust 100% okay.
If I take a match and I take a yellow piece of paper from this particular
notebook,
I will light that motherfucker file with that match.
That's a fact.
Okay.
That's sight of the fact is it?
And though it's a scientific fact,
but it's not higher than hypothesis is just hypothesis you up.
Why?
Because every time you've seen a fire touch of piece of paper,
it burned it.
So you're relying on your historical experiences.
You're essentially saying there's no scientific fact possible.
Only to the level of hypothesis we can.
This is not me talking and this is Thomas Quinn.
I shouldn't be saying,
look,
he's saying,
we have two phases in science,
standards,
science,
and then a scientific revolution.
What Standard Science?
Well,
whatever the flavor of the day is.
Let's say today it's,
let's hit the dates,
evolution.
And then he said,
look,
every every piece of information that we receive,
we interpret it through that Lens.
He called it a paradigm.
We look at the information through the lens of evolution,
so it makes sense.
It fits right here in our story of evolution,
right?
And then he says,
look,
a small amount of contradictory information is going to pool slowly.
It's inevitable.
He says,
and then this,
we're gonna ignore it.
We're going to sweep it under the rug.
Everything doesn't make sense.
And then one day,
that level of information that,
that,
that amount of information that doesn't fit in any way with our theory or
current theory is going to pull and pull and pull and pull until one guy comes
around and says,
no,
we had a backwards or we had it wrong.
It's this and now all this new information fits in the new theory.
All the old stuff fits and all the new stuff fits and that's called the
scientific revolution.
And he says science is always going through a normal phase and then a revolution
phase and man is becoming more and more precise but will never reach the level
of past hypothesis.
Why?
Because science is based on our faith that their past,
excuse me,
that the future will behave like the past.
We only know things via experience,
VR history.
So when I flipped that coin,
you have no idea what's going to happen until I flipped many coins in front of
you or I give you my ex.
If you trust me and I tell you what,
listen,
I did this experiment,
here are my results and you trust me.
You just take it for granted.
You,
you take it on.
We have authority.
I agree with everything you said.
I still don't see where you're saying science has so much.
Whew.
Okay.
Or science has this much woo as healers or crystals,
suckers or listen,
I don't believe Trump stills in any of that.
I know you don't.
I don't.
I just,
I have a higher standard of skepticism.
I'm missing the Wu though.
Okay.
The Wu is when we project physical laws,
combustion,
electricity,
gravity,
these are all appeal to magic.
Can you demonstrate these,
these physical laws or are they byproducts?
Are they,
are they inferences you made in your mind because you've seen a certain pattern
over and over again,
that law doesn't exist out there in the universe.
It's only a bookmark.
It's only a name we have for a pattern.
We've observed the nature.
It's pretty heavy stuff.
I know it's only a name for a pattern.
Exactly what we've observed that exists in nature.
Exactly.
So that means you can't label anything ever because everything is just a pattern
that we've observed in nature.
Everything is a pattern.
There is no,
there's no logic behind that.
We give an explanation,
we give a narrative to it.
Okay,
but that narrative is just our paradigm.
Commas cone would say that's the shades you're wearing.
Okay,
that's you.
You can't set a beautiful,
he said,
look,
you have pink tinted glasses.
You could have blue tinted glasses,
but whatever glasses you're wearing,
that's the song and dance.
That's the,
that's the,
that's the story you tell yourself of why those things are happening,
the way they're happening.
Okay.
The truth of the matter is,
all we're seeing is one pattern happening over and over again.
So what this is essentially is an intellectual exercise,
but the reality of our ability to come up,
whatnot,
hours are obviously super smart.
People come up with the very technology that we're using right now to broadcast
this podcast.
It means that they have figured things out,
that there are provable and that you can use science to determine what frequency
things need to be,
how much electricity you need,
what kind of components can you know,
take the image and projected through the power lines and through the Internet
cables and all the different things that we need to be in place to provide the
electricity to provide the Internet connection.
That's all science.
So this is all predictive sites is predictive,
right?
But this is all,
these are all things that are not just observable,
but they're repeatable,
right?
The pattern.
Where's the woo?
Here's,
here's,
here's where the rule is.
Okay.
Our explanation for why it happens,
the laws of nature are woo.
It's not woo.
It's are you our words that we use to describe repeatable things.
Okay.
Which,
which,
which law of which force of of of nature are you referring to?
Let's pick one at random.
Miss,
can you show?
I don't think that is a force of nature.
Okay,
so with you,
that randomness.
The idea of randomness.
Okay.
Pick one because they use it.
They say it's,
it's evolution of a natural section via a random selection.
Temperature.
Okay.
What causes to observe temperature like you?
I believe temperature exists.
What causes temperature?
We don't know.
That's true.
And we don't know.
We,
you and I don't know any science.
They don't have any idea what causes only.
Tell me about the pattern regularities.
That's it.
That friction causes certain things that the magnetic pull of the sun on the
earth causes certain temperature shifts and the,
these are recognizable and repeatable and they understand how to measure them.
These are all just patterns and regularities found in nature.
Right.
And they're giving them names and explanations.
I see what you're saying isn't explanations can be debunked later on.
I put them in the maybe bio plausible pile,
but this is,
this is,
listen,
I know it's frustrating,
but the philosophy of science,
this is it.
The cause and effect.
We do not observe cause and effect.
We do not observe one thing causing another.
We just see a and then we see B.
It's really,
it's really,
it's a bit difficult,
but imagine this,
we see and we see B,
we don't,
we don't see the cause of connection because if we did see the causal
connection,
you would know what happens.
When I flipped that coin,
you could have predicted it.
You called predict what's going to happen when a file,
exactly how much force you're exerting on your thumb.
To flip that coin,
I would have to know what altitude we're at to understand what the atmosphere
that this coin is going through.
I would have to know the weight of the coin.
I would have to know that the position of your thumb on the thing,
it's like what you said about the billiard balls,
that that is true,
that if you could calculate the exact amount of friction on the cloth into
table,
the amount of Polish that are on the balls,
the amount of force,
you'd have to have all the balls in the exactly the same spot.
But this is,
this is not possible today too.
Dang.
If you set up a table and you set up,
let's say just say nine balls and you told me you were going to know where every
ball was to the millimeter,
I would say I will bet you $1 million you're wrong and I would be right every
time.
You're never going to get it.
Why?
Because you don't have the ability to calculate all those very,
but it's theoretically passion.
It's also the physical,
the physical change of the amount of force that you drive when you break those
balls varies and it varies even slightly.
It's going to change the way.
So a person just doing it with their body is not capable of that kind of
precision.
If we got a robot to break,
even if you've got a robot to break,
you would have to have those balls in exactly the same spot and they don't
usually sit that way because the cloth has fiber in it and it's wool.
It's a worsted wool and that worsted wool moves and shifts and bends and it
flattens out in some spaces and other spaces.
It gets dirt and debris.
In Charleston,
there's too many variables,
so because we cannot compute all the variables,
I'm with you.
We can,
maybe we can create a tool with a slight margin of error.
Right?
Well,
they'll still be a margin of error.
That's why Laplas said I'd need a divine calculator.
Yeah.
He said,
we don't have to even round off the numbers,
so I'll be slightly wrong.
Right.
But the argument is that if we had all the variables and that's a big,
if it's logically possible,
it's logically coherent with the reality that we see.
Yes.
Random.
This is by the wayside.
It's a figment of our imagination.
We projected when we cannot compute,
but if we could,
this is a objective outside of us,
right?
The truth is outside of it's not dependent on me and you how we see the world.
So randomness is based essentially on our inability to calculate variables.
It's not on an actual law itself.
Yes.
When we say that's random,
it's wool,
right?
It is and the strictest way of the,
of the word.
Now,
every logical law.
Now this,
this,
this is what hurts people,
but I love science.
Look at me.
I'm Ramallah lover of Sinai and I'm a,
I'm a,
I'm a science addict.
Can I read all the books?
I'm fascinated by science.
Let's say I take object x and I throw it out that I throw out a window.
What's going to happen?
I don't know.
You don't know?
I haven't experienced with object,
object X.
I don't know what object is.
Why can't you?
Why can't you produce it?
Why can't you do this?
What's going to happen?
Well,
if I had more information than you need experience,
you need a history with object x.
You need to get to know object x,
interact.
You cannot deduce it.
While you would write down all these different variables,
you would find out what people have learned from the past about these variables.
Now we'd be science.
Exactly.
Science is the history of patterns and regularities.
It is not.
Deduction is not logic.
It's the type of lighter we call inductive logic.
This logic is the faith that the past,
that the future,
soon in the future it will behave like the past.
So the patterns and regularities we see in nature,
we say,
look,
if these happen often enough,
we can recreate the circumstances.
Often enough,
we predict it will happen in the future.
We have a faith that it'll happen again in the future.
There is no logical reason why it does.
There is no not one single logical reason.
While we don't fall off the fall off,
fall off the face of the earth.
Every explanation we give ourselves is just a narrative.
It is always subject to interpretation.
However,
with the change in variables like the shifting of the Earth's magnetic poles,
or I gave you a ridiculous narrative and the Gremlin one just to show you,
look,
I know you don't believe in mine.
I don't believe in my neither,
right,
but I'm doing the same thing Isaac did
and I'm going to correlate my Grumman's three as far as he can correlate his
gravity theory.
He used the word gravity.
He made it.
He made it sound better.
He made it sound less ridiculous,
but the truth of matter is he's throwing his hands up in the air and saying,
look,
I don't know.
Let's just call it gravity.
Let's,
this is the way to think about it.
Now.
His contemporaries laughed at him.
They said it's an appeal to magic.
And then when people started wearing those shades,
those paradigms,
they're like,
hey,
it makes sense if you,
if you believe,
if you,
if you just believe in gravity for a second,
it explains all this ballet of,
of celestial bodies and how they move.
But really what he discovered was a pattern.
And he gave that pattern in name.
But does that force exists out there?
Well,
not according to Einstein.
He came up with a different narrative that fits the evidence even better than
than Isaac Newton did.
But it's still a narrative.
It's,
it hasn't removed all the other possibilities for something to be true.
Without a doubt.
For it to be knowledge,
not belief.
There has to be zeroed out,
meaning no other possibility whatsoever.
That's knowledge.
So my,
so can you know something that's untrue?
You cannot know something that's untrue.
You could believe something that's untrue.
Knowledge means that this is known.
There is no possibility of doubt.
That's what Descartes was such an important philosopher cause he gave us one
thing that we know the cogito.
Have you heard of the Cognito?
I don't remember what it is.
I think therefore I am.
Oh,
okay.
What is it that we know?
For sure.
Cause cause you know it's funny,
there's two great philosophers that I've read that they went through a crisis in
their life.
One of them was amen because Ellia grid Arabic philosopher and one of them was
Ernie.
They capped and both their writings are very like they're,
it's amazing.
Why?
Because they go through this crisis.
They go through,
what do I actually know?
What's not?
Because they came to this exact same conclusion that hey,
it's all song and it's all us explanation.
It's not proof.
It's all a narrative.
It's all a point of view.
Science keeps getting refined and changed.
What we more information,
what we believed yesterday gets taken out from underneath us.
Today's paradigms is going to be shifted again a hundred years from now,
a thousand years from now.
What can I grab and be like,
this is true.
Nobody can ever take this from me.
That's going to be called knowledge.
So it all comes down like at the end,
at the end of the long journey of Cartesian doubt.
They was,
it was so extreme that the philosophers give it a new name.
They call it Cartesian dot.
They call a modern philosophy.
So philosophy is thousands of years old.
Descartes comes,
writes a book.
He wrote six chapters in six days and he was like,
what do I actually know?
100% without a doubt,
nobody can ever question me.
And he said,
look,
I believe in the Cognito.
What's the Kogi too?
I think therefore I am.
So he goes through a long process.
You know,
if we have the time,
we'll,
we'll go through a little nutshell of it says,
look,
this is,
when I,
when I put a straw in a glass of water,
my eyes tell me that the straw is bent,
right?
Because the reflection of the waters is,
is bent the light,
the reflection of the light off the water.
He says,
look,
my eyes light to me.
Aristotle thought the sun goes around the earth,
his eyes light to him,
our senses lie.
And he talks about if I put my hand in cold water,
then I put it in tepid.
They'll seem warm to me.
But that's just my bias,
my inability to tell you what my,
my,
my instruments are not accurate enough.
So he said,
okay,
let's,
let's put the
empiricism or senses by the wayside cannot give us truth.
Can I give us truth?
He says,
what about deduction?
What about math?
And the local knowledge,
one plus one equals two.
Believe it or not,
philosophers also disagree with a lot of mathematical,
uh,
beliefs.
So for instance,
here's a,
here's a big critique of math.
Okay,
one plus one equals two.
We all believe it,
but the critique is that one plus one is another way of saying too,
there's no actual information you ever gave me.
Mathematics is just one way to sum up a lot of information.
It helps me give you an epiphany.
It makes,
it makes me,
it helps me make you understand what's happening on the billiard ball table.
We'll give you a calling,
one plus one.
Two.
You're not changing the objects themselves in.
It's always been two things always been too.
Yeah,
it's a tautology.
You're just explaining to me something that's out there already existing.
So if I tell you a triangle has three points,
why when it said the word triangle,
I already told you how three points,
but maybe you didn't pick that up.
Maybe you had to point it out to you.
So Bertrand Russell said,
beautifully said,
look,
I've firsts in his career.
Burton Russel is a very,
he's a great thinker.
He said,
look,
mathematics is the thing we're more sure of.
By the end of his career.
He was like,
guys,
I'm not even sure about math anymore.
Why?
He's like,
I think math is just another way of saying a four legged animal has is an
animal.
But you said that when you said it's four legged animal and he just repeated
yourself by saying it's an animal.
If I say there's my wife,
I married her when I said my wife,
I told you I married her.
That's what math is doing.
Math is giving you the information again in a simpler form that you can
understand and you think,
oh,
I've deduced this instrument.
No,
actually the information was there in the question,
right?
Some,
some philosophers disagreed with this.
They said,
no,
math brings you like can't,
can't said no.
Math tells you something.
Okay,
let's put that on the wayside.
Here's another critique.
One I personally could never get around is they look,
he says,
look,
all of the greatest thinkers in history,
there's actually an urban Timia critique of,
of a logic.
He says,
look,
all the greatest thinkers in history all disagree like Plato and Aristotle.
You know,
Plato Tutored Aristotle,
two of the greatest thinkers in ancient history.
They don't agree with one another.
They do.
They both think they both say you're wrong.
And then I said,
I'm wrong.
Okay.
Fast forward.
Every generation,
their greatest thinkers disagreed.
Lightness didn't agree with Voltaire Today,
Sam Harris and and Jordan Peterson to,
okay,
maybe they're not the top,
top intellectuals of our world,
of our on earth today,
but there are there among the,
among the elite.
They don't agree on what is true.
When you ask them what's truth.
You guys are talking about truth all day long.
Can you define it for us?
We don't agree.
So if logic is something tells us about the world.
If it is,
let's say we grant that they caught saying,
look,
we can't use it.
We don't,
we're nobody's good enough to use it and get to a conclusion that everybody
agrees upon.
So he's saying,
look,
even that doesn't help me.
So he came up to the Cogito,
he says,
look,
he doubted everything.
Like he even went to the point where he said,
what if I'm dreaming?
What if there's a evil demon are,
they're always tricky.
My,
he went really out there like that's one of the reasons why simulation theory
theories to yeah,
people really do what series people consider the potential that not only is it
possible that we are in a simulation,
but that there are many,
many simulations inside of simulations because we couldn't,
that's the egocentric predicament we were talking about earlier is you can not
experience anything outside of your consciousness.
So you could be plugged into a machine right now and this is just a big old
dream could be,
and that's why they cart.
The wanted to know what would be true even if I was in a simulator and that's I
think therefore I therefore am because for me to have thoughts,
I'd have to exist.
If you doubt the Kogi till you've proved the Cognito guest to object to it,
you first have to have existence.
Bryan,
right?
He refined it,
I think.
I think thinkers refined it later on and before him also many thinkers came to
this conclusion.
He just did it really famously.
He did it.
We did it in one sentence too.
He did it in one sentence.
He summed it up.
That's why if you,
you know,
I've heard of Ockham's razor.
If you use OCKHAM's razor to an extreme,
if you go create,
if you go to an extreme degree,
if you everything with adult,
you chop it,
everything that might be imaginary,
inferred,
logical,
empirical,
you chop it.
What happens?
You have a transcendent experience.
You'd become you.
If you take off all your paradigms.
And this takes a very brave human being to do,
to remove everything that anybody's ever told you and have the experience of the
one thing,
what you would know,
what you would come to with mystics.
That's why I believe that there's,
there's a place where you can get where religion is true and science is faith.
And I know it sounds crazy,
but there is a point and I believe in science,
don't get me wrong,
I'm a,
I can't precise science enough,
but there is a transcendent experience a human has.
And that transcend experience is consciousness itself,
not the content of consciousness.
This is where people make a mistake.
Consciousness itself,
reality.
Your world is nested in consciousness.
People think consciousness is within my brain.
It's the opposite.
Your brain,
your body,
your uh,
your,
your self is in consciousness.
And when we,
when we get to this point,
then all our paradox is disappear.
There's no more paradox.
The logical paradox is maybe if we have time,
we talked about logical paradoxes,
they never end.
But when we,
we understand that our world is nested in consciousness.
There's nothing happening in the world around you that's outside of your
consciousness.
It's only outside of your eagle.
The thing you would you associate with Joe Rogan
is also happening inside your consciousness.
Your brain is within consciousness.
No Brene has ever been observed outside of consciousness.
See and flow in materialism.
We have this,
they have this philosophy called Epi for nominalism that the consciousness is a
byproduct of this physical brain.
We have this physical brain and your consciousness is like a byproducts,
like a smoke.
Now we asked them,
how do you know about this physical brain?
All we know it because of our consciousness.
If your consciousness is fake,
unreal,
then souls,
your brain,
your brain's,
the reason why we all know about brains is because of conscious consciousness
tells us about brains.
So brains are dependent on consciousness,
not consciousness dependent on the brain.
So I know this is a bit of a tricky thing,
but this is what idealism is all about.
There is no physical object outside of consciousness.
It's all mental construct.
This is d,
this is what we,
this is,
we started this podcast talking about it and then,
and we ended on our mind.
Fuck yeah,
seriously.
This is a serious mind.
Fuck the egocentric predicament.
Not In a,
not an easy one.
Well it's a,
it's,
it's a fascinating yet impractical exercise because you will,
you will do it to the end of time.
It'd be sitting here debating and discussing and dissecting the very,
but you know,
that's also how you gain a greater and deeper understanding of all the things
you have no idea what the fuck they are.
Exactly.
But it's,
it's still,
it's still amazing to me.
Like how much is to be explored about what is real around this,
like the world,
the reality of the world around us is it's,
it's,
it's greater than any mystery and an existence.
That's why for me,
I can't read fiction.
I only study science,
history,
philosophy.
That's the only thing.
Science,
history,
philosophy,
religion.
Cause it's weird enough.
No,
because it,
they're all trying to tell me they all trying to explain the world around us and
it's such a hard thing to do.
To sum up what's,
what's reality.
Hey,
all these philosophies and theories are trying to sum it up.
This is reality and to cross examine them.
For me,
it's far more entertaining than watching them
movie or hearing a fictional story.
Hmm.
Yeah.
No,
I get it.
I mean it's definitely fascinating and entertaining and a,
I liked fictional stories too though.
I like,
I like observing creativity because I'm fascinated by the human experience and
I'm fascinating by what people were able to create out of their own mind.
Something like we were talking yesterday about Stephen King about how amazing it
is that this guy just keeps continuing to create these bizarre stories and that
someone can do that.
The your consciousness and by putting so much emphasis on creativity and your
ability to just write down things that never really happened and paint a picture
inside someone's mind.
Yeah.
Let me ask you this.
If he is,
if determinism is true,
who wrote the stories like when your retic has passed,
when you read it,
when you write a story on a computer,
did the computer write the story?
No.
You wrote a story.
Right?
But if determinism is true,
Stephen is just the computer and his buttons are being pushed by it.
Past events.
Yeah.
So that's why like one student asked me,
hey,
you should read a book by Sam Harris on determinism.
Like,
well,
can you ask Sam who wrote the book?
You know who wrote the book and the terrorism is going to say,
well,
he did.
Now he can write anything.
He's determined.
These are old philosophical questions that need to be explored,
but they are,
like you say,
a mind bending,
you know,
very mind bending for us.
I'm glad we finally get this right.